for me that's a sign of movement
immaturity if we're going to sit around
and who's more oppressed
black people female people
this per what what are we doing
these are qualitative differences when
you reduce
qualitative difference to quantity it's
an old mathematical and philosophic
problem there's something going on there
that you ought to interrogate
before you answer the question
i want you to know that this is not a
debate i've watched almost all of your
interviews like debate debate
heated debate with marxist like this
these are questions
i have i think of me as a fool i don't
know much
you're a scholar i
i'm just a filmmaker just a humble
obsequious filmmaker
i'll ask you questions and peter will do
the same
you do know i hope that the scholar
is exactly described honestly as you've
just described yourself
it's just that the scholar functions in
an institutional arrangement
where he has to or she now has to
position himself herself um
as some kind of expert some kind of
raised being and that's you know
if you have some compassion it's
something that the academic
fell into it shouldn't be blamed on the
academic
i mean granted they abuse it and they
exploit it and all the rest they do
most of them do and that's been my
experience
and i've been an academic all my life
but
they're not the author of their own
sad position and they often
stumble in their own personal lives and
in their academic environments
because that posturing as the scholar
who knows
is a heavy burden and it it doesn't work
well
and it even the scholars would be better
off
if they could stop that fakery and
get on with talking honestly about their
ambivalences their uncertainties
the parts of the story they can't tell
because they don't know
instead of looking upon that as like you
know
some defect that they have to mask
find it on opening for an interesting
conversation it's sad
very sad but then there's no tenure or
maybe that's why there's ten
that's right and then if you're unsure
you know the tendency is to play
one-upsmanship games with other
academics and to utilize your power
position relative to students
to you to work off on them to act out
your own
uncertainties your own lack of
confidence
which then in turn because the students
always pick it up
makes them turn off to education and i
think in part
become an audience for you all right man
peter all right so my name is
uh peter guinos and i'm here
with kirchio mongol kurt
uh filmmaker and head of
better left unsaid we are here today
with dr wolf marx's professor
who is going to help us shed some
clarity
on some of the ideas circulating around
marxism both
in the past and in our times
so my first question uh for you dr wolf
is uh do you mind just starting by
telling us
in the audience a little bit about
yourself your past where you're coming
from
and what you're working on now what
you're working towards
okay i am the
child of two immigrants who came to the
united states from europe
my father was french my mother was
german
i was born in the only place my father
could get a job as an immigrant when he
came here
which was as a steel worker in
youngstown ohio which is where i was
born
um i grew up speaking mostly french and
german because that was
those were the languages of my home
i really only started learning english
when they
dropped me off at my kindergarten to
start
public school
and i'm very grateful that they had the
wisdom to
teach me these languages so that i grew
up basically being
trilingual which for a child is very
easy to do
and much easier than learning languages
later on
um but as the child and i was the first
child of immigrants
who had fled europe because of the war
and who kind of had the death all around
them as part of their lives
there was a pretty heavy burden on me as
a child
to fulfill the life
ambitions that had been cut short for my
parents
because they had to leave the countries
and the positions and the careers
that they had had over there
so i was early on oriented towards being
a proper achiever and since my mother
was german
achievement always meant physical
as well as mental capability and ability
so
i always played sports as well as doing
academic work and being a good student
i had to be a good student because if i
came home with anything else
both my mother and father would begin
tearing up
uh i just say that to give you an idea
of the level of psychic pressure
there was so i ended up um
being a very good student and an athlete
and i played the violin in the orchestra
the whole bit
um and in those days
uh harvard university was making an
experiment
and bringing in people who i think
normally would not have been brought
there so i went to harvard as an
undergraduate
um where i was told why would you not
normally have been brought there you
said that you were a great student a
great athlete
uh my experience at harvard where i
spent four years
well let me explain i went to harvard
and when i finished at harvard i went to
stanford and when i finished at stanford
i went to yale
so i am i spent 10 years of my life
in this rarefied atmosphere of the elite
universities of this country and i know
both because of what i learned there and
what i have learned
umpteen times since that this
is a highly stratified society
who sends its children to the same
universities they went to
et cetera et cetera et cetera and i'm
not part of that my parents had nothing
to do with that they came from another
part of the world
i didn't go to harvard by the way
because it was harvard my parents didn't
know what harvard was
the guidance counselor in the high
school the public high school i went
to thought i should apply to harvard and
i did but that was not my first choice
at all i wanted to go to where a friend
of mine had gone
a small college called oberlin in in
ohio
that i had visited and loved but harvard
gave me more money and my parents had no
money
so my father said well this is easy
you're going to harvard so
i went to harvard because it was cheap
for me
given the fellowship and all the crap i
got
i learned once i got there what this
place was and i've learned since
how it works but people like me do not
normally end up
at a place like harvard that really the
fact that i was good in school or played
football or any of the other stuff
really uh very nice but it's not it's
not what happens
and partly it's not even harvard that
rejects you it's that you don't even
think
of applying there it's just not part of
your universe and it wouldn't have been
of mine
had it not been for the guidance
counselor's
uh desire that someone from our high
school get to harvard
and i think that year i was their best
shot anyway i went okay
let's let's get to your current work and
then what you're working toward
okay um i didn't like how this country
treated my parents as immigrants they
were quite grateful that they were alive
and they gave the united states credit
for being alive so
they weren't the critics i was but i saw
what
happened what what kind of lives my
parents led
and i didn't blame them i blamed the
system
that was an early insight of mine and i
i stayed with it
ever since i gave myself the task
understand how and why this system did
what it did
to my parents and and the people around
them that i
got to know so i've been a critic
of the system for as long as i've been
more or less of an adult and
i found it an interesting challenge that
harvard
and stanford and yale did their level
best
to persuade me otherwise and i took what
they were trying to teach me seriously i
didn't dismiss it i wasn't
glad handing what they were offering
but they didn't persuade me they really
didn't
and what i also saw which has been a
very important
shaping of my life i saw
naked fear i saw it over and over again
at harvard at stanford and at yale
and here's what i mean i would raise a
question
or other students it wasn't just me that
had something to do with the critique
of capitalism and i could see the way
any human being can see it in another
the fear in my instructor's
faces and i'm including here the
instructors that i like who were good
teachers
and the instructors that i didn't
particularly like who weren't such good
teachers
and this is around 1970s 1960s yeah it
was in the 1986 mostly the 1960s i mean
my basic education is tonight
in my period of going to the ivy leagues
these three schools
that's the 1960s okay and you attribute
that fear to what
uh the cold war mccarthyism whatever you
want to call it
my professors had two problems basically
the first problem was they often didn't
know the answer to the question that i
asked
they simply didn't know and you know in
the academic world as you've probably
discovered
it's very painful for a scholar to say
i don't know as if that were some
fundamental
defect that they should be ashamed about
so they were fearful because they did
not want in front of a classroom of
young
folks like me to be in the position of
saying
i don't know but they didn't know
because
marxism was so toxic
to them in their environment at that
time
that it went to the point of not reading
the books not learning the arguments
or the other kind of fear uh was just oh
my god don't
i don't want to go there this is
dangerous material please ask
somebody else please go somewhere else
with your question
and whatever they said to me their faces
were like
um tableaus of anxiety
and difficulty and i you know like any
young person i think with half a
bit of curiosity to his or her soul
i wanted to understand what's going on
here
what what's happening why is this
every time i bring up something about
marxism or socialism
or communism which by the way were front
page
news in the daily newspapers all the
time
at that time what in the world is going
on here
and then i began to ask questions and i
began to learn
so let me let me make a simple statement
that summarizes it
i spent 10 years of my life at harvard
stanford and yale
one professor in all those ten years
assigned us one
passages from karl marx's capital
his major adult work of analyzing
capitalism
one professor during one semester
happened to be at stanford by the way
not at harvard and not at yale
and i have one ba from harvard
three master's degrees from stanford and
yale
and a phd in economics from yale now
there is no excuse
intellectually or any other way for such
a lopsided crazy
curriculum that's not about analysis
that's not about priorities
that's about political fear
career fear these professors did not
want and if by the way if you were to
ask me
might some of them have been sympathetic
the answer is
they might have been but they were so
scared that i'll never know and i can't
answer your question
if you have that in your mind by the way
the united states we're living in right
now
is itself the product of an entire
half century of self
censorship that makes it impossible for
large numbers
of perfectly intelligent uh human beings
in this country
to have a clue as to what the critique
of capitalism means
around the world the power it has the
influence
it has i can't get it it's a mystery
that
continues to overwhelm them okay could
it also be
that as you mentioned in one of your
other interviews marx is so
has already influenced our critiques of
capitalism to such a degree that we
don't necessarily need to go back to the
source for example in physics we never
read newton
we don't read archimedes we know about
what newton has influenced we don't go
to the principy of mathematica
in biology you don't read about lamarck
because that's outdated although you
might hear
about why lamarck's theories are
incorrect you don't go to the source so
could it not also be that
it that would make sense if the great
marxist thinkers
since marks were on the reading list
but they're absent also part of the loss
of not reading the original which by the
way
isn't that old you know marx's mature
writing
is 150 years old it's not inaccessible
it's not you know from another universe
but even put that aside
i could give you a list of 20 or 30 or
50
marxists who came afterwards who
developed the thought
often critically dropping this focusing
on that
extending it over there those are not on
the reading list either
because the topic is the problem
the whole approach it it's like dealing
with
childishness among academics i don't
want to see it i don't want to
hear it i don't want to know it's there
and the end result is you don't know
anything about it
look i have the following problem as an
academic
i had to learn neoclassical economics
which is the dominant
paradigm in this country i had to learn
that because i had to teach it
and i had to get my exams passed
properly
and i load keynesian economics which is
the only
slightly critical approach that is
allowed
so i can talk to my colleagues about
what we share
but the minute i start talking to them
about marxian economics
they don't know what to do it becomes a
difficult conversation
because they become at best the pupil
and i become the teacher and that's not
the relationship they want with me they
want the relationship of colleagues
not as teacher student and so the
conversation
dribbles off or dies or even takes an
unpleasant turn
so i've learned as people like me have
had to learn in the united states
to talk the marxism in a different
language
so that they can hear it and can maybe
process a bit of it
instead of having the visceral reaction
which they mostly have
not realizing it's to their own
detriment
the creation of these parallel languages
to circumnavigate the center's impotence
in discussing these topics is
something that's not unfamiliar to our
time
uh i'm curious do you think that
uh these the creation of these taboos
around marxism
in the 1960s were simply because of cold
war tensions or does it
highlight an institutional problem in
our education system
in universities or some other aspect of
our education system
well no because the the irony is before
the cold war sets in that is before
1945 to be precise
you did have across the american
academic
spectrum quite a few
seriously critical voices
yes they were not as freely allowed in
academia
as they should have been i would be the
first to say that
but there was nothing like the wholesale
silencing that you had in the aftermath
of 1945.
i'll give you an example and i'll do it
from economics because that's the field
i know one of the great economic
economists of the 20th century
uh was a man named paul sweesey
s-w-e-e-z-y
you can look him up lots of books very
funny cite him in the transcript
okay uh ironically a member of the
rockefeller family here in the united
states
uh the rich ones um
who also went to harvard by the way uh
but in a way parallel to mine
he ended up being a marxist long story
short
uh teaching at harvard where he had gone
to school
he was a professor um and one of the
great
inspirations to call to paul sweezey
as a marxist at harvard was the american
theorist and economist thorsten veblen
whom i hope you know or if you don't you
ought to learn one of the great
thinkers on the left in the united
states
before world war one even let alone
world war ii
uh and sweesy was in fact responsible
for
keeping his legacy if you like alive
veblen taught school in a variety of
american universities
uh sweezy taught at harvard but with the
end with the cold war harvard in a
typical gesture of academic
courage fired sweezy
okay he was the person who was
designated
as a young instructor to fill the shoes
of the most famous professor
at harvard in economics at that time a
man named joseph
schumpeter all right he was retiring he
was an old man
and sweezie was his prized student
despite all of that despite all of
sweesie's
connections not only as a thinker and as
a successful student
but as a member of the rockefeller
family and let me assure you
that harvard takes a great deal of
interest in anybody who has anything to
do
with the rockefeller family as do all
these universities
but he they fired him because he was
politically unpalatable
and he went on to found a magazine uh
called
uh monthly review i'm not sure you're
familiar with it
uh it's been a socialist marxist
magazine
in the united states here it continues
to publish now
uh it started in 1949 when paul sweesey
got together with albert einstein
who was a socialist who wanted to
support marxism
i mentioned it only because most
americans have
cleansed mr einstein of his unfortunate
political interests
anyway they started this magazine
together einstein and sweezie
in 1949 call month review
uh in which by the way i have published
articles full transparency
here uh but that kind of thing is was
normal the professor who who by the way
who the only professor i ever had who
assigned
marx was a man named paul buran
b-a-r-a-n
was a professor at that time in stanford
and had gotten the job uh
immediately at the end of the war
because of his
uh participation in the oss
the office of strategic services which
was the forerunner in the united states
of the cia he had been a leftist
and had been working as sweesy and
others did
in the anti-fascism movement which one
included collaboration with the very
same government that later
turned on them uh when the wind
changed but yes it it devastated
american academics
and by the way let me be clear it still
does
the cold war ended in 1989. at least
that's what the history books tell us
with the implosion of russia and eastern
europe
but you wouldn't know it if you go to
academic economics in the united states
today
it is as lopsidedly unwilling
to admit the entire corpus
of marxist scholarship today as it was
30 years ago it i find it stunning
i find it something that really merits
some
uh analysis and one of the reasons if i
can be
personal that you find your way to me
is because i am a product of that elite
that opens doors for me because i went
to those universities
if i had gone to other universities all
other things equal
you would never have heard of me and we
wouldn't be having this conversation
that's part of the power of the ranking
structure of american academia
and it's been true all my life let's get
some definitions out of the way
for people i'm a man of definitions
what's marxism
what's communism and what's socialism
very good
let's do that marxism you know that's
easy
because it has something to do with karl
marx and it has to do with
with a remarkable reality about karl
marx
uh the man lives from 1818 to 1883.
he does most of his writings around age
30
and afterwards so you can narrow down
the middle of the 19th century
as the core of marx's writings
uh so we have what is 150 years more or
less since then
uh and that body of ideas that he writes
quite prolific just a footnote in case
your your your
audience isn't familiar uh marx is born
in germany
um but he's exiled but that's the way
they punished the political
leftists in those days they didn't kill
him they didn't
arrest them they exiled them so he left
germany
um went to france they did the same went
to belgium they did the same
and he ended up where all refugees from
europe in those days did
in london which allowed you to stay
there so he lived the rest of his life
in london
uh spoke english taught in english wrote
in english
but mostly in german because that was
his basic language
in 150 years since marx died
his writings have inspired
marxist thinkers in all
fields natural science social science
humanities you name it in every country
on the face of the earth
it's one of the most stunning spreadings
in a historically short time 150 years
is not long in history and there's no
country on earth
that doesn't have its marxist
institutions marxist
intellectuals you name it so it's
everywhere
which suggests if you're not close to it
that there's something going on in this
set of ideas
that an awful lot of people find really
interesting okay professor i'm going to
get you to be a bit terse
what is marxism what is socialism what
is communism i want to
make the most of your time i know you're
getting it all right fine
uh socialism is a different thing
socialism existed before marx as did
communism
those were existing things that marx
encountered
he had positive and negative reactions
to them
broadly speaking in terms of what these
words have meant
a i have to tell you that there is no
single definition there is no
institution that issues
definitions that everybody subscribes to
when you hear that word used you have to
look at the context
you have to read a bit because what
people mean by these terms
has always been contested terrain
that's true of most social science
issues but it's true
in spades of this one so here's what
socialism
has come to me and i'm going to narrow
it down to
three basic alternatives to help you out
number one the kind of socialism
associated
with scandinavia western europe and a
whole lot of other societies
works roughly like this you have an
economic system
in which private enterprises are the
dominant
form however these private enterprises
are organized in a very particular way
which is called capitalism namely
that they organize themselves with a
very small number of people
in a very dominant powerful position in
modern capitalism these are called the
major shareholders
or the board of directors or if you know
how a corporation works
the major shareholders elect the board
of directors
and tell them what to do this is a tiny
number of people in most enterprises the
vast majority of people in most
enterprises
are called employees whereas the first
group are called
employers but the way capitalism is set
up
all the key decisions about every
enterprise are made by a small minority
that is not accountable to the large
majority in that enterprise
all the key decisions are made including
those
that impact the vast majority
but the vast majority is excluded
from participating in the decisions they
simply have to
live with the results which include
firing them and not paying them any
money and throwing their families into
whatever dilemma that involves that's
how private capitalism works
and then they interact these enterprises
with one another
by means of market exchanges that's
typically what we mean by capitalism
and the socialism of western europe
as the prime example involves the
reaction
of the mass of the people to the
grotesquely
undemocratic arrangement of a capitalist
enterprise
by wanting some relief
and the way they get the relief is to
utilize their political power
to get the government and remember we're
talking about societies
in which universal suffrage exists to
get the government
which they vote in to regulate control
and limit the private enterprises that's
called
socialism sometimes it's called market
socialism
sometimes it's called social democracy
sometimes it's called
democratic socialism bernie sanders and
aoc
like to call it democratic socialism the
europeans who they're copying
like to call it social democracy that's
one kind
now there's a second kind and on this
second kind there's a
debate is it socialism is it communism
here's the second kind and then i'll
tell you what the debate is about
the second kind has the government
intervening
not really one moment before we go into
the second kind
because you said there were i just want
to make sure we we have our ground
consolidated
so we said that there were three key
characteristics of socialism yes
uh one that there is this private sphere
that is uh disproportionately
designed to favor those at the top the
major shareholders the employers
and this is at odds with a regulatory
force from the government in the
democratic society of universal suffrage
right these are
two forces that are kind of fighting
each other in socialism are these the
features that define
uh socialism just i just want to make
sure before we hey
they define the first kind of socialism
okay so the first kind so
here's the second thing yes the second
kind
is the government steps in and takes a
much more active role
it displaces the private
owners and the private directors
of the enterprise it gets rid of them
think of the soviet revolution in 1917.
it gets rid of them and it replaces
all of them with state officials
the government is now usually by in
russia it was called the council of
ministers
it sets up a government apparatus
in which government persons people who
have a
official position in a governmental
apparatus
replace the major shareholders and
the board of directors and and so we
talk of in economics we talk of state
enterprises
um but i want to underscore some people
still call this socialism other people
call it communism
that's usually a question of not being
very clear
about what happened and what the people
themselves say
and being lost in the propaganda of the
cold war
let me give you a simple example in
russia and china
the the political party that makes the
revolution
calls itself the communist party
but never let me underscore that
never have either the chinese or the
russians
called what they set up as communism
that's a western invention they called
their societies
socialist for them it was a kind
of socialism in which the government
went beyond
regulating as in scandinavia and western
europe
to actually operating large sections by
the way never 100
but large sections of the economy
as a governmental uh exercise
ussr stands for the union of soviet
socialist republics it's a socialism
and the communist party of china refers
to china
as a socialist economic system with
chinese characteristics
but the notion of a communism was
always in those societies the place
toward which the political party was
hopefully
taking the country not a status
that had ever been achieved so the
soviet union disappears
before it could arrive at communism
okay now so you have two
two competing versions of socialism in
one
the government is regulated bernie
sanders aoc
folks like that in another one you have
the government taking over russia china
vietnam
cuba and so on that's what they do
now there's a third and the third one is
emerging now
because of the historical experiences
of the first two see we have
a century of the first kind of socialism
and we have now a century of the second
kind
we have a lot of experience with
socialist governments
regulating private capitalism
i i for example can tell you if you're
interested
about portugal portugal has been
governed for the last several years
by a coalition it comprises the
portuguese socialist party
the portuguese communist party and the
portuguese green party
i will not embarrass you by asking you
whether you were aware
that portugal has been governed by this
coalition
over recent years if you are typical
americans
you had no clue and that's the
seabees that comes to mind in greece in
greece
there's definitely a movement right yeah
but syriza didn't last real long
and the portuguese experiment did and so
it
it is a counter example in any case
here's my point the the russian
and the chinese and the western europe
and the scandinavian
these kinds of socialism have now been
tried
over the last century and while they
achieved
much that is valuable they also
experienced major failings
major failures major setbacks and the
job of the marxist movement
that tries to understand and analyze all
of this
is to understand both the successes
and the failures so that the experiments
will have taught us something and the
next phase
will be more successful and better than
these
early experiments in going beyond
capitalism
so what we're getting into the third
phase and as a preface is this the one
that you advocate for
absolutely so here's the third
definition
of either socialism communism i really
don't care about the language
all that much the third version of
socialism or if you like
communism has to do with
the response to the analytic
of what the first two experiments in
socialism
of the last century have taught us
and here's the biggest single lesson
since our time is limited
that the changes made both in the
european western
socialism and in the russia-china
governmental apparatus was that what
they changed
was what we in economics call the macro
level the big
level of the economy they never
here comes the punchline they never
radically
altered the internal organization
of the enterprise the factory the office
the store
where the work gets done where the goods
and services are produced
and distributed they left them
as a small group of people at the top
making all the decisions
and the mass of people being excluded
from the decisions but required to live
with the consequences of those decisions
from which they had been excluded
therefore
the analytic runs as follows the
failures the flaws
of the existing experiments in socialism
can be corrected can be improved upon
if we take the step of radically
democratizing the enterprise
making socialism be not just
a macroeconomic change but fundamentally
a micro economic transformation
in which you leave behind
the dichotomy employer
employee which i would argue
is simply the modern version of the
earlier dichotomy's
lord surf master slave
get rid of them democratize the
enterprise
it becomes a community
governed by one person let me finish one
person
one vote where all the decisions
what to produce how to produce where to
produce
and what to do with the profits or the
net revenue or the surplus depending on
how you think about these things
are made democratically the
democratization of the enterprise
was not part of european western
socialism
and it was not part of soviet chinese
socialism either footnote
for the last seven years the cuban
communist party
has been making a major effort to
develop
what are called worker co-ops which is
what i'm talking about
and make them an important part of the
cuban economy
so there is movement but that idea that
socialism needs
the micro level democratization of the
enterprise
that's the third kind of socialism if
you like
communism if you wish because the word
communism then
goes back to its root community common
and that's what it is to make a
community a democratic community
out of the workplace under the slogan
you're never going to have political
democracy
unless you build it on a foundation of
economic democracy
and that's what this kind of socialism
advocates
so that idea of communism comes from
commune
with those utopian commune experiments
and in was
interestingly enough there was uh
a movement to communes pre-soviet union
in russia that kind of helped spark that
so this idea of you start small and you
create these smaller experiments and
then you scale them to the
you know to the larger picture to the
macro picture uh is definitely something
that wouldn't be unprecedented in the
history of
of communism let me add there are many
experiments and they weren't just in
russia they were all over the place
there were many experiments in what i
would call
the communism of a worker co-op type of
enterprise
there were many here in the united
states that i'm i'm speaking to you from
and in canada as well so it's all over
the place
there is nothing new in a sense what you
have
is a determination now to institute it
on a social
scale and one more thing because it
seems to
trouble americans when i talk this
notion that you start in a small
group a couple you know a communal
workshop that has 10 people in it or
20 people and then you build from there
as somehow not workable
i got news for you that's how capitalism
developed
the early capitalisms that came out of
feudal europe
they were tiny they were five people and
10
people and they had to learn how to grow
in the process of growing they invented
this joint stock company the whole
notion that you could have a
owner who wasn't on the spot working
with you
those were traumatic and difficult
transitions
they will be difficult for the
collective democratic communism
too but no one should think that because
you started small
that makes you in any way different from
every other economic system
and on that note right of joint stock
companies marx
when he writes on co-ops mentions that
right he says with the development of
cooperatives
on the workers part and joint stock
companies on the part of the bourgeoisie
the last pretext for confusing profit
of enterprise with the wages of
management
was removed and profit came to appear
in practice as what is undeniably
right sorry as what is undeniably
uh was in theory mere surplus value
value for which no equivalent was paid
he says it's in the third volume of
capital and so there's definitely this
this discussion
with uh cooperatives do you feel that
cooperatives in your review of marx are
cooperatives
do they take to do his writings on
cooperatives take essential
rules or do they take a sideline role
if this is sort of the true marxism
wouldn't we expect marx to just mainly
focus on
cooperatives yeah i would never argue
that it's marx's main
goal let me remind you a little bit
about marx
um he he took the analysis of capitalism
as a whole as his project and he
and that's crazy nobody can do that no
single person could ever do that
he undertook it as the french would say
fought demure
because it was the best he could do and
so he was going to try it
he only finished volume one volumes two
and three were put together
from his notebooks and his scribblings
volume two by
uh by engels and volume three by kowtsky
people who came after him or were
colleagues of his
so they made the decision given what was
in the mind
their minds at the time of what was
important and what was not and which
notebook would be
developed and which wouldn't etc etc so
marx's comments on co-ops which weren't
a major historical phenomena were
secondary to him you know he didn't
write about the state
either there's no marxist theory of the
state
there's very little on world trade and
stuff like that
these were important topics we know that
because he said so
but he didn't get to the kind of
analytic
of them that later marxists have been
able to do
so i think what you what you see is
people like me given what happened in
the
century after marx died building up on
parts of his analytic
that other people uh found less
important because of the times in which
they live
i'm not sure what in the world exactly
you would want to infer from that
one more example when i first started
getting interested in marks in economics
my
reading led me to believe that there was
a very important question
about the relationship between marx's
theory of value
on the one hand and explaining market
prices on the other
since i was taking courses in economics
i can tell you that
at harvard yale and stanford all
economics is about explaining
prices it's sometimes called price
theory because
that's what it focuses on it took me a
long time to figure out
that marx wasn't interested in prices
that was for him a secondary tertiary
issue he was interested in conflict
between
classes he was interested in the dynamic
that makes uh capitalist societies
function and change
and for him prices were a minor matter
and you have to understand that but
marxist for a while
didn't and went through enormous
connections
trying to figure out how to transform
the value system marx articulates
in volume one and three with the price
system uh that western capitalist
economics
deals with since i was a mathematician
it was quick for me to understand that
the mathematical
posing of this problem missed the whole
point
even though it engaged an entire
generation of economists
because after world war ii what was lost
to economics
in terms of the broader social issues
was replaced
by a fetishization of very simple mind
and math
and arithmetic which the economists
thought
was the greatest breakthrough imaginable
but wasn't so in the past too you've
talked about how
private property and the idea of
government ownership were something that
marx
didn't really have as a central focus
and it's sort of mistributed
uh to his his works right you say
uh you would have to search long and
hard
in the very voluminous works of karl
marx
to find one word about this he wasn't
interested
in the government he didn't write an
article or a book about the government
he wasn't interested and so this
this misattribution what caused it
a strategic decision made by socialists
in the 19th century kind of thing that
happens in
all schools of thought as they evolve
as you read marx as people like marx and
he wasn't the only one in the 19th
century not by a lone shot
and you you became aware in the middle
of the 19th century
that the great promises of the french
revolution
had been betrayed that the french
revolution had said to the europeans
that if you bring in capitalism to
replace
feudalism you will achieve
liberte
liberty equality and brotherhood and if
you deal with the american revolution
add democracy that capitalism
brings those human values
into reality that was the promise of the
french revolution
because that's what it was its slogan
liberty equality fraternity
okay by the 19th century critics
were able to make the following insight
capitalism sure has replaced feudalism
but as a mechanism to deliver liberty
equality and fraternity
it is a 100 bust
it failed and the only interesting
question was
for them why why
did this promise get betrayed
marx's answer was
it got betrayed because
capitalism itself is the obstacle
to achieving liberty equality fraternity
of course it could not bring what it is
itself the enemy of
and he devoted himself to making that
case
in his writings and he succeeded along
with others
so by the middle of the 19th century you
have
an enormous body
most beautifully encapsulated in in
german-speaking europe
uh austria on the one hand and germany
on the other
uh in terms of the spd in germany the
socialist party of
in german the country is called
deutschland the spd
socialist party of deutschland and in
austria the flourishing of marxist
theory
uh on a scale no one had ever seen
before was the first
flower of the postmarks generation of
marxists
who by the way were personally connected
to
uh sigmund freud uh rudolph carnap
lutwick wittgenstein and all of modern
thinking
which is another reason why excluding
marxism from the curriculum
is such a mind-bending craziness anyway
the question then became in the 19th
century how are you going to get from
capitalism
to the socialism that can bring liberty
equality and fraternity in the way
capitalism couldn't
and the answer they arrived at was
grab the state see if the mass of people
can get their hands on the state
because that will be the strategic key
way to move
if we get this state then we can use the
power of the state
to make the transition beyond capitalism
because there's no other way to get the
liberty equality and fraternity
that we have been motivated by the
french revolution
to seek so the focus on the state
becomes a strategic decision has nothing
to do
with the basic theory it has to do with
how we're going to get there and the big
debate then becomes by the end of the
19th century
do you grab the state by means of a
violent revolution
or by evolutionary parliamentary
politics and that's what engages the
state becomes really important
and what about for you is violence ever
justified
to bring about socialism only if it's
the self-defense
if the bourgeoisie can't leave quietly
then they'll have to leave some other
way
well when you say self-defense violence
can be interpreted as words
as we've seen on some of the
contemporary discourse like you're
assaulting me with your words
there are various ways of defining what
self-defense is so when you say
self-defense
what are you meaning by that
well in the world as i see it today the
monopoly of physical force
is in the hands of governments that are
in turn
agents of and tools of the capitalist
system
which they are devoted to reproduce
if the mass of people don't want
capitalism anymore
then the question becomes what is the
capitalist part of the society that has
the control of the monopoly of means of
physical force
what are they going to do if they exceed
to the will of the people to move on and
have a different system
then we don't need violence but if they
decide to use their monopoly of force
and the way i read history they don't
hesitate at all
then the question becomes for us will we
defend ourselves
or will we not speaking of force
what lenin lenin in the state and
revolutions
he doesn't like judges he doesn't like
police he doesn't like the military
because those are tools of the
bourgeoisie
do you what do you see what do you like
or not like about the defunding movement
defunding the police movement well i
don't
i'll be glad to come back to that let me
can i just finish the other point that i
was making because
i was still answering this question
about the state that that yeah before
go on go on my friend okay um
so here's what happened socialists
figured it out
they figured out how to get to state in
russia they did it by a revolution
in western europe as in portugal as i
gave you an example a minute ago
they did it in parliamentary means and
you know they've done it
quite successfully in many countries
socialists
have taken political or state power
now the question becomes once they've
done that
given the theory and the strategy
developed in the 19th century
how are you going to go about making the
transition
which is why you got state power from
capitalism
to socialism and at that point
very very important the capitalists
understood they had been defeated
they tried every whichever way to block
socialist parties
from coming to power violently in many
cases
but they failed they couldn't do it the
socialists outmaneuvered them
and became players in turkey in terms of
the state
the response of the bourgeoisie of the
capitalists if you like
was then to cut a deal having
lost the effort to prevent socialists
from state power now they had to deal
with the reality that the socialists
had it and again make a long story short
although we can go into it
the deal that was struck was we the
capitalists
will undo you unless
you come to terms with us and coming to
terms with us
meant a redefinition of socialism
no longer would it be the
process of a radical alteration of
society
no no what it would be would be
to be blunt capitalism with a human
face we socialists will be in power
but we'll make it softer we'll force the
capitalists
to have a minimum wage we'll force the
capitalists
to offset the horrible capitalist a
business cycles
with some other kind of
modify you know we'll have an
unemployment pro socialism will become
[Music]
a less harsh capitalism than
it had been before just
don't mess with our dominance
in the enterprise and that's why it's
important to understand
with marx and hence my the quotation
that for marx it was never an exciting
question
whether the government played the role
of capitalists or a private person did
who the capitalist is is not the
issue it's the capital it's as if you
had said to me
uh slavery didn't exist in such and such
a society
because alongside the private slaves the
government had slaves
who the hell cares nobody would question
slavery on the grounds that the
government played a big role
or feudalism and let me tell you by the
way that slavery and feudalism
had governmental apparatuses that had
slaves and had
serfs the fact that there are
governments that have employees
doesn't change that it's capitalism it
just says their state capitalism
alongside the private which is in no way
unique to capitalism
and it has squat to do with socialism or
communism
other than as a moment in the history
when a strategic gain was undone
by a redefinition of what socialism
meant
so from the sound of it uh these
socialists get into power they become
the government
they strike a deal with these
capitalists
and you know the corruption starts there
my my question is
who are these capitalists is it possible
that the socialists get in the power
and they have no intention of sharing it
um
that is to say that they quickly become
exploiters themselves and that it's the
state that sort of dooms
marxism as as opposed to these more
anarchistic strains of marxism
that focus on the bottom up like worker
co-ops
uh communal living in the woods
somewhere like in
the case for russia or the peasant
commune
is the state and this is against
conventional wisdom i suppose but is the
state
antithetical to marxism
well that's been a debate inside marxism
for a very very long time
in the middle of the 19th century marx
himself had a political alliance as well
as a personal friendship
with a russian named bakunin who was at
arguably at that time
the leading theorist of anarchism in the
world or for any period of time
and they worked together they together
formulated the international working
men's association
which was the beginning of the
internationals that we've had ever since
so from the beginning marxism and
anarchism have had a very
complicated relationship sometimes close
sometimes
hostile to one another and so lenin is
the person who coined the phrase
when asked his question what do you want
the state to be
in in your new society he says our goal
is the withering away of the state and
and and to dismiss that as some kind of
you know trumpian verbiage is not to
understand a long history of
engagement between marxism and anarchism
precisely
on what is the role of the state both as
a transitional
strategic issue and as a long-term
institution
you said trumpian it's interesting
because bannon actually says he loves
london for that
line uh which is kind of crazy but
anyway
um so but i want to know what you think
do you believe that the state
is antithetical to marxism i also like
mr bannon because i think his concept of
charitable foundation is one that ought
to be more widely understood
um i'm sorry your last question was
that's interesting okay uh my last
question was
do you believe that state is
antithetical to marxism i get the
broader context
um i.e was bakunin or
maybe more preferable anarchists
krapotkin
tolstoy were they ranked on the issue as
opposed to the marxists
well i've always understood them to be a
necessary compliment to one another
which is why i think they got together
in the first place
in other words you're going the old
marxist
argument was the state is the agent of
the ruling class that the state
is an institution designed
to reproduce the society as a whole
in the manner that the ruling class
wishes it to be reproduced if you got
rid
of the dichotomy between ruler and rule
that exists inside the enterprise
then there wouldn't be a need for the
state
and it would then wither away
and on that basis a deal could be made a
strategic
alliance in principle and in practice
between marxists and anarchists
in order for us to get rid of the state
we need
the democratization of the workplace and
in order to
solidify the dominance socially of a
democratic workspace
you need to get rid of the state okay we
have a shared objective
if we work together we can together
better achieve the shared objective
than if either of us function on our own
so let's not only not be
enemies let's be allies with the
conjoint
goal of getting rid of the state and
creating the institutions at the base of
society
that can make sure the state is a not
necessary
and b not allowed to return
while we're on the way to getting rid of
the state what about defunding the
police
and also i'm curious to know what your
thoughts are on some contemporary issues
like
the black lives matter movement and do
you see them furthering the cause of
marxism
well i think like most movements um they
have within them
the potential or the or the actuality
of uh merging with marxist movements
allying
with marxist movements cooperating with
marx's movements
and they have within them the potential
to refuse any such thing
and to reject it and that those issues
and those questions
are in fact being fought out inside
if i ask myself why the rockefeller fund
gives as much money as it does to black
lives matter
i think i know what the answer is and i
understand
what why they're doing that and why they
have always done that and why the ford
foundation
does it also it's a question of shaping
as best you can which way this
internal debate in a movement like black
lives matter
works when it comes to defunding the
police
for me these are strategic questions uh
not
principal questions the police function
in a certain way in our society
and they do that for particular reasons
i do find it strange to
imagine and i hope most of the people
pushing this are not
doing what i'm about to say but to
imagine that you can go at the
to the last step of a long process
namely what the police do
fix it without changing the contacts
that makes it what it is if you defund
the police
and you have some other agency step in
to do
god knows what it will end up doing what
the police do
because you haven't changed the social
system within which
the police are given their tasks paid
their money
rewarded and punished for the things
they do and don't do
that's what has to be changed otherwise
you're just changing the personnel
or changing the who of the of the
behavior
rather than the behavior and its place
in the social system
then it sounds like we've once again
returned to the more anarchistic
tendencies
of starting from the bottom up as
opposed to regulatory change from the
top
down um i unders i understand why
anarchists like to believe that this is
anarchism
but it isn't the anarchists have no
monopoly on the notion
that you do social development from the
bottom up the marxist movement in many
many of its incarnations
has been rigidly clear that its
logic is to transform at the base
and force it onto those at the top this
is
the anarchism shares that with marxism
absolutely
no doubt but it shares it it isn't
the sole carrier of a notion of
bottom-up development that
that's really given that anarchism has
been a much
smaller movement around the world than
marxism and socialism
always and everywhere i mean i think
it's
fair to suggest that these are shared
notions of development and putting the
adjective anarchist in front of him was
a little strange
let's imagine our guests would own the
label uh i think it would be very
against
that philosophy to only label even their
own
but i i agree
no label the bottom up they're making
men
ask the question who in the various
actors in the social drama
who's committed to the a notion of
bottom-up transformation
and who isn't and there's i think where
you get the
the debate inside socialism these days
are we in favor of the government doing
12 more things than it currently does
or are we in favor of a bottom-up
transformation and the worker co-op
movement
is a bottom-up notion of of social
change
which calls itself socialist communist
marxist
and so forth okay bottom-up imagine you
can
advise the people of the black lives
matter movement as a whole they're all
watching this
what would you change
redirect about the movement to make it
more efficacious in your
estimation i don't know
i wouldn't have taken to on myself the
position of
articulating either such a question or
an answer so i don't know what
what i would say i would hope that
um the anti-capitalism
which i already see is present in the
black lives matter
statements that i've read interviews
i've watched and so on
i would hope that that's a growing
deepening uh commitment that that
an awareness that the problem of um
of an other in a capitalist society
which exists everywhere in the world
has landed on the african american
community
uh from the beginning here
to understand the role it plays and to
be insistent
i guess that would be my my hope to be
insistent that the transformation
beyond capitalism is a central part
of what can finally uh
liberate african americans from the
subordination
that they have suffered you know in this
society for so long
there's been a debate whether or not
the root cause of
much of the suffering for the
african-american community in the united
states
is economic or racial and
i believe it was sanders who said that
the the root problem of
our country was economy it was something
that we needed to fix
and i believe it was uh one of the
leaders of the black lives movement
who directly refuted him and said no
the problem is ultimately racial
to me this sort of strikes the
difference between
this more let's say it's called the
older
left guard socialists and
the newer identity politics tendencies
of the left
do you find that this is a divide that
might uh
stunt or present a stumbling block to
socialism
what should be the socialists attitude
towards identity politics
well we don't all mean the same thing by
these words but let me try anyway
uh to get at it i find the discussion of
what the ultimate cause
of things is boring
i don't know exactly what's at stake
here i suspect
it's organizational turf uh
and i don't like it or prioritization
well you know that's a very different
thing priority is one thing
you know we all make priority i decide
what i'm going to do at 10 o'clock today
and i don't do something and i don't do
something else but i don't make the
world depend on it
i don't say that one is the more
fundamental i
i give a priority i'm more touched by
something
than the next person my autobiography is
different from yours
and therefore i don't expect that the
things that you know
spark my passion are identical to yours
and i don't find that interesting your
mother was not mine
your community of growing up was not
mine you're a different person for me
and we can have different priorities i
assume we have different priorities
i think every political movement that
ever got anywhere was a movement of
people
who had different priorities but
understood
the need for a movement that captured
that
brought together people who had
different
priorities and therefore having the
debate what's the most
important thing strikes me is odd
i'm not sure let's decide moment to
moment
day by day what is a good target for our
activities over this week
over this month and and some days that
decision
will be shaped uh this way and other
days it'll be shaped that way
we make our priorities tactical
strategic
and so on but we do it knowing
that each of us is a different person
with different motivations different
personal
priorities and i'm okay with that i
don't think there's any way out of it
anyway the trick
is not to debate what's the most
important that strikes me as nutty
you and i don't have the same standards
for that that's what we debate
and then we vote and then we see how it
works out
but the rest of it the rest of it
strikes me
and here you get my my suspicions get
aroused
what is the motivation i worry
what is the motivation of posing the
question
since it makes no sense to me i wonder
why are we
asking whether it's more fundamental
to harm the economic change than the
racial change or the
you name it change do we re for me
that's a sign of movement immaturity
if we're going to sit around and who's
more oppressed
black people female people
this per what what are we doing
these are qualitative differences when
you reduce
qualitative difference to quantity
that's an old mathematical and
philosophic problem
there's something going on there that
you ought to interrogate
before you answer the question
it's like what you do if a person
accosts you in in a dark space
and says i'm gonna give you free choice
i can either bash you over the head with
this
brick or i can stab you if you start
agonizing over which way to go
in this question you've made a strategic
error
because the response there is i don't
accept the question
not that i'm going to choose which is
the better answer
and for me that's how i react to what i
think you mean
by identity politics okay well i have a
quick aside about the dark space
i'm gonna accost you in it you mentioned
that
let's imagine we have socialistic
societies and capitalistic than the
socialistic
if by your definition they come about
they would be more free that this
capitalistic societies have promised
freedom
liberty use the word liberty but haven't
delivered however liberty freedoms
are qualitative distinctions yet you're
saying that socialistic
in your definition of worker co-ops
being engendered and pervasive
would allow for more liberty and that to
me is a quantitative
now analysis because you've said more
which is less more less than is you know
less or equal than sign
okay so how are you transmuting this
qualitative
notion of freedom to a quantitative and
why does that not suffer from the same
problems that you just outlined with
measures of oppression let's say
if i made a verbal slip and i made
quality into quantity
then you're absolutely right to catch me
on it and caution me about doing that
i don't think i did it but i'm sure i
i'm the product of the school systems in
which i was produced
and making that kind of slip it's an
epistemological slip
it's part of the game that you as you
learn and as you change
i would insist that what the socialists
are about is a changed
quality of what the word liberty would
mean
what the reality of a society that
honored liberty equality and fraternity
would have would have to mean and that
that's necessarily built in
because we don't mean the same things by
these words liberty equality fraternity
i mean people who are carrying guns into
midwestern courtrooms
because they don't want to wear face
masks
use the word liberty to describe what
they're doing they want the liberty
to breathe on other people with the
disease it's like asking me
for me it reads like oh i want the
liberty of going through the
traffic intersection without paying
attention to the green and the red light
i mean i understand the use of the word
liberty
but it has no no residence for me i mean
by liberty
something completely different from that
which they don't recognize and i
understand that
so i shouldn't use words like more or
less because we're really talking about
very
differently qualitative notions of what
would exist if we may defend the idea of
setting priorities
and you know especially in political
movements as to what is important and
what is not
important and which ones take precedence
you know if there's a current debate
but not only between identity politics
and
socialism that you find on the ground
that is a debate
that transcends what's on the ground but
even bubbles up to policy
uh decisions as to whether or not
funding should be directed more towards
people of particular groups or
to the poor in aggregate or in general
when it comes to this idea of liberty
that you mentioned with the masks
people storming into armed gunmen
storming into
these government buildings you could
argue even here there is a debate
between which liberties triumph over
which other liberties
does my liberty to breathe on you with a
disease
uh triumph your liberty to
trump your liberty to not have me do
that and
to me i think the answer is kind of
clear on that one person but
you know some people do not think so so
i think it is worthy having these
discussions even in a
liberal society as to where
where do our rights take precedent where
do
our issues take their importance
anyway so when we look at
the world now and we see this
conflict between identity politics and
socialism
could i could i interrupt sure
i don't like that way of posing it and i
want to just object
to it i for me
if i'm advocating for what i guess
is meant here by socialism i'm
advocating
on behalf of people who are employees
and who have an identity as
such so i am an employee
i may also be a male i may also be white
i may also be educated i may also be
unskilled
i may be all kind i have lots of
identification lots of communities if
you like
in which i participate and the composite
of
all of them makes me who i am
i wouldn't understand that i'm more
a man than i am white
or i'm more an employee than i am
white or any i don't understand
literally
what i'm supposed to make of these
things
again for me a successful political
movement
is an alliance if you like or a
coalition or whatever word
you want of people who have
different sets of identifications
that get together because they can
define
a common objective and they can work
together
to try to come up with strategies and
tactics
to achieve whatever the common
objectives
have been determined to be that's what i
think of and a socialist
contribution is to bring
for me the organization of the economy
at both the micro and macro levels
into play as among the varying
identities each of us brings
into the possibility of a social
transformational
movement i'm curious to know where you
disagree with marx what are your biggest
gripes
biggest gripes um
well you know it has to do with the
tradition of marxism
afterwards um i'm a little bit
pissed off that he did not write
as he had promised he would or that he
hoped he would
uh the works about the state the works
about
international trade the works about what
we now call economic development
um i think there were problems there
i think that the early work he did with
engels
around the analysis of of
household male female relationships
particularly
in the household uh was a wonderful
beginning
and i i'm i'm distraught that more work
didn't follow about that whole
quest the origins of the family um
and how that linked up to the rest of
capitalism
uh i think marx could have
worked more than he did he did great
contributions but he could have done
more on why
the paris commune of 1870 marx is
still alive at that time and he writes
very famous pamphlets about
the paris commune and at that time it
was the first
effort to go beyond capitalism
in a major european country france paris
um and his own people were involved in
it
he wrote a very good essay about what
went wrong but he could have done much
more
since lenin used marx's writings on the
paris commune
to shape his strategy for the russian
revolution
had marx done more work analyzing
particularly
the ambivalence of the rest of the
french about the paris commune
it would have cautioned lenin in ways
uh that i wish and here's perhaps the
biggest one
marx also made comments about worker
co-ops
uh as lenin did um they recognized the
potential
but they did not do what it is i'm
suggesting now
has to be done they never devoted
an analytic focus on asking the question
how should socialist society
transform the workplace let's remember
that's where most people spend most of
their adult lives
nine to five five days of the week you
go to work
it defines those five days you prepare
for work you do your work
you recoup from work you go to a bar to
have a happy hour to cope
with what the work meant to you it
shapes your personal life it shapes your
sexual life it shapes everything about
you
one would think that marxists focus on
the working class
including how the workplace shapes the
ideological
openness of workers to a movement for
socialism
that there would have been on the part
of marx and marxist later the kind of
analytic
focus on the household on gender
relationships
on the identification of sexuality and
so on
so i think those are areas that marx
disappoints me because i learned so much
from what he did focus on
i wish he had given comparable
analytical attention to those kinds of
topics
you know as we were talking before we
said that a whole
a large part of this channel is about
when does the right go too far when does
the left go too far
and you can pull a gnome chomps and say
the only the right goes too far
even though he admitted that the left at
least the democratic left has abandoned
the working class
when do you see the right is going too
far ideologically speaking and when do
you see the left as going too far
like can equality be taken too far can
diversity be taken too far
you interpreted it as you wish
well i'm not clear i understand the
question but
being a student of uh marx requires one
to be
in my judgment anyway also a student of
marx's philosophic teacher
and marx's philosophic teacher was a man
named hegel
and one of the things hegel argues in
his work
is that everything is contradictory
and that if you don't see the
contradictions
in something you're not getting it
that there's stuff you are occluding
and then it becomes a psychological
question why you would do that
so i don't expect liberty freedom
quality to be uncontradictory concepts
so when earlier it was said i don't
remember which of us said it
that the liberty of one person is is the
absence of liberty to another
that's exactly what hegel would argue
that's not a
flaw in someone's understanding of
liberty
that's what liberty is it is a
contradictory
reality because all reality is
and now pardon my language over
determined anything we can think about
anything we can touch anything we can
see is
over determined by everything else going
on in this society
you or i are shaped by countless
literally an infinity of economic
political
cultural natural phenomena that impinge
on
us the air the water the dream
the the comment of your boyfriend or
girlfriend or whatever
all of those things shape us and
they shape us in different ways they
push and pull
us in all together we're full of the
resulting
contradictions that emerge as the other
side
of our over determination and that
applies to
liberty or african-american-ness
if that's the right word or any other
construct
that we come up with mentally or
encounter
in our physical world so i'm not i don't
find it a
flaw of the concept of liberty or
anything else
that people don't agree about it see it
differently
experience it differently want it
differently
that's what social life is in part a
struggle in which we all push
for whatever at those varying moments
shapes us as a desitorotime something
we would like to to push for
professor edward stewart i'm not sure if
you're familiar with him he's a
comparative economics professor at
northeastern illinois university
he said i have a question for richard
wolfe and he's a keynesian he's
okay he said biden wins what's the match
you can advise biden what specific
policy would you
like to see enacted i would advise him
to resign
okay your president what specific policy
would you enact
i suppose i would go i would take my
clue
from uh bernie and
aoc and would enact a uh
a green new deal i would uh
enact a government hiring program
that would deal with our unemployment by
basically saying that anybody who lost a
job from a private employer
ipso facto now has a job
at at least equivalent pay from the
federal government
uh that would get us 20 30 40 million
depending on how you count
people who would now be a new labor
force for the government
they would not be governed by
profitability calculations
as private capitalists are they would do
what is socially useful
that would begin by testing everybody
for coronavirus
to determine what kind of strategic
public health
initiatives are necessary because that's
based on who has what disease
growing in what numbers in what regions
and that would employ millions of people
and the rest would be employed
on the kind of ecological new deal uh
and by the way this would simply be a
step
one in which we recoup and recuperate
the policies that worked well in the
great depression because that's the
situation we're in now
uh and make them uh the opening gun
and then i would because of me me
then i would turn to an enormous program
of uh the creation of a worker
co-op based sector of the american
economy why to give americans for the
first time
the knowledge with which to make a
freedom of choice
real they're going to be able to choose
between working in a
hierarchical top-down undemocratic
capitalist
enterprise or a democratic worker co-op
i would create through government steps
the kind of sector of the economy
that already exists in italy in italy if
you go to the province of amelia romagna
you will go to a place in italy
a province where 40 percent of the
industries
are organized as worker co-ops i would
replicate that in the united states
so that every let me finish that every
american would be able to know
because in his or her community or in
his or her family there's someone buying
from
or working in a worker co-op
democratic enterprise so everybody would
know what it
is like to work in and shop from
such an enterprise so that you could
choose in a rational way
what kind of economic system you want
you wanted half capitalist
half worker co-op two-thirds one-third
75
25 100 one-way let's see
let's put the whole question of the
economic system
to a democratic decision based on a
population
that has some idea of what the
alternative is
those are the kinds of steps i would
take i have no illusion
neither mr biden nor ms harris
have the idea the concept the capability
or any history enabling them
to do any of this so
one just a footnote to show you how the
world changes
kamala harris somewhere does have this
and the reason is her father
her father is a colleague of mine
her father thinks like i do
he's a marxist a marxist economics
professor
and he was at stanford for most of his
adult life
bringing it all the way around uh
nice so my question for you is what are
your thoughts on
uh quotas that help that are racially
or gender-based quotas to help correct
inequalities
do you think this is a viable strategy
two correct inequalities
well it should never have happened i
don't believe it could ever have
happened
the quote from the inequality both
but the quotas have been part of
american education
if you're talking about quarters in
education but for me quotas anyway
there's a fellow named will kim lika uh
who's
sort of the father of this sort of
statist version of multiculturalism
that's very popular here in canada i
believe he's the
dean of political science at queen's
university
and he's he advocates very much for uh
that style affirmative action but across
the board for all sectors
not all sectors but sort of replicating
and expanding that into other
let's say uh institutions yeah well
i may end up in the same place for me
the american education system just to
take that as an example
uh has been a quota governed system
from day one for me
capitalism is a quota based system
there's a quota on capitalists there's
only a certain number of them
and the rest of us get to be employees
who
are told what to do by quota is built
into this system and there's always been
quotas
you know it used to be that the quota
was you had to be white and male
and that was it you got into the
university and if you lacked either of
those two
there was a quota and your quota was
zero
and then if you made a lot of noise your
quarter would be two
you're talking unspoken quotes as
opposed to formal or are we talking
formal as well because the
neighborhoods used to have right now
yeah the quotas the quotas are on the
continuum
from formal written legal all the way
over to informal
illegal unspoken you know and everywhere
in between the quotas
but the quotas have always been there
however they have been construed
all that that the modern struggle over
quotas
uh seems to me to represent is the
determination
which has always happened to quotas that
sooner or later
as the society changes the quotas have
to change
because the relative size and strength
and political power
of the different quota groups alters
and sooner or later they're going to
want the quotas to reflect
what their social power or their social
position
or even their social consciousness tells
them is appropriate it's a little bit
like international treaties
they're always out of date about the
time they get signed
because the power relationships among
the countries that sign the agreement
changes and therefore it's only a matter
of time
before they want the documents governing
their international relations
to reflect the change in their actual
economic and political
statuses and i think that's what quota
struggles are about the african-american
community
wants to be let in and not blocked out
i understand that they were blocked out
for a very long time that quota was zero
or next to zero or or maybe zero plus a
few
um you know examples to look good but
they want a change across the board
in their exclusions which were always
kinds of quota system
and women want the same thing and latin
american uh
immigrant groups want the same thing
right i mean if you look at like the
history of the white flight right you
can look on the deeds to old houses and
see
in this country they were called
covenants all kinds of communities
did these things some of which had legal
status of covenants
in which uh a developer for example
would
require everybody who bought a home in
some
area to sign a document that he or she
would not sell it to a african-american
jew or that's horrible whatever it was
yeah and
my question is do we fight old quotas
with
new quotas no or do we get rid of voters
no my guess is the only way you can
fight an old quota
at this point given it's the depth of
its thing
is to do what you you can offer a no
quota system
but you can't deliver it so it's a bit
of a phony
because it's baked in it's cemented into
the system it operates on a thousand
levels that's i think what the phrase
systemic racism
is designed to gesture toward that it's
built
in on a general way across the system
and a change here or a a law
adjustment over there that's not going
to do it you've got too many things
that will get re-create let me put it
this way
reinstitute the effective quota that
existed before
even when you got rid of it here because
the forces
that made for those quotas haven't been
addressed
you know for sure for sure 100
i mean the idea of systemic racism is
that it goes so deep it
goes beyond just the formal state that
the informal power systems that we have
in our society
that embed that ideology but at
the end of the day do we have say
something like a formal quota like
affirmative action
well for me i don't think that works
i'm not against it but i don't think
that solves the problem
and i i tend to be critical because i
see it
as a way of kicking the proverbial can
down the road okay
we're going to now have x percent of
these that's not going to change
you know what is fundamentally going on
in this society
i would rather go at it from the
systemic
change if we agree that there is
systemic
racism or systemic sexism or whatever it
is
let's deal with the system that
supposedly underlie
what would it mean for example that if
that you
made it a fundamental right of everyone
in the united states
to have a job to have the job pay no
less than
80 percent of the median wage in this
country
and that everybody is entitled to proper
housing
that has to be at least x square feet
per purse
i mean suppose you really began to deal
with the quality
of the job and the quality of the income
and the quality of the housing
and the quality of the neighborhood
services begin to say to everybody we
really
are a society that does not
allow a ghetto over here a ghetto over
there
uh whole industries that are female
versus
industries that are male and all the
rest that we know exists
if we don't do those basic changes the
rest of it
strikes me as substitution for solution
not solution well it was stalin who said
that
quantity has a quality of its own yes
you know yeah well he that's where you
begin to get
the hegelian the brilliance of what
hegel did why hegel becomes the great
thinker for all of europe in the 19th
century everything in europe
that happens starting around you know
1810 or 1820 everything is derivative of
hegel
the influence is overwhelming and and by
the way in most countries this is kind
of grasped
in the united states of course not
because
they are so irony is the association of
marks with
hagel also condemned poor hegel
to be ignored too maybe
i once gave a talk at yale to a
philosophy
seminar where i tried to explain
why students interested in hegel and
there were a few
despite the department's hostility
why they should be interested in marx
and they were terrified
by the way they were terrified it was
another example of what i began
our conversation with the anxiety of
association
you get anywhere near this marxian
paradigm and you know
like a child with a hot stove keep your
fingers
away but they didn't want to go anywhere
near marx even though marx talks at
great length about his hegelian heritage
what it was what was important about
hegel what was
buried in capital from hegel and and
said really and this notion of
contradiction
and this notion that that that
things don't exist versus don't not
exist
but that existence and non-existence are
two sides of the same thing
just and where that leads you and what
that opens up is so
sad that americans you know don't get it
it just closes off like the like the
paranoia about marxism
it closes off vast realms of
knowledge for no reason at
all other than to pander to a short-term
political narrative from people they
don't respect
at all it's extraordinary
how does the contradiction in the
hegelian sense not lead to the principle
of explosion
i don't know what the principle of
experience so that is from any
contradiction you can derive
whatever fact you like unless the proper
term is to call it a hegelian paradox
which is like an apparent contradiction
it's not a true contradiction
a and not a the hegelian notion is that
a
and not a have a boundary between them
and that that boundary is a property of
of both sides
so that not a is a property of a
and vice versa that's my understanding
of hegel's notion
so our we can't conceptualize
our life without conceptualizing
our death our life is bounded
by our death and that makes death part
of life and vice versa
that for me that's what the hegelian
notion of contradiction
uh involves and it means that everything
that exists
is in the process of not existing it has
its own
not existence in its own
being in its own definition the arrow
flying through the air
where is it and the answer is it's
always
where it is but in its movement it's not
where it is
okay i know that you've been extremely
generous with your time
i have while i got you i got some labor
theory value questions quick okay
i i i have another five minutes then i
have to go that's fine totally fine
okay if you want we can do this again
thank you so much i appreciate it i want
to call you richie most people call me
rick
so you can call me rick all right rick
the problem i have with the surplus well
why don't you quickly quickly outline to
the audience the labor theory of value
very quickly in simplest terms when you
sit down with an employer
and you have a conversation about
getting a job here's how the
conversation
basically goes here's what you're going
to be asked to do come at nine
leave at five sit over there work with
this machine do this work
why are you there because i already have
a bunch of machines and i have an office
and i have a factory and i have a bunch
of workers
i'm adding you to all of that
and i'm doing that because by adding you
i can improve
either the quality or the quantity or
both
of the outputs the goods and services
that this enterprise is committed
to producing so by virtue of adding you
i'm gonna have x more
product to sell let's assume
that that's worth a hundred bucks
so now the question is what am i going
to pay you
to come and do this work
well the answer is i'm going to do a
little calculation
i'm going to count up the extra raw
materials and tools
that are going to be used up in making
the extra 100 bucks worth of output
let's say that's 20 bucks okay now i
know what i got
i'm gonna have a hundred bucks output
i'm gonna have to spend 20 bucks of
tools equipment and raw materials
that leaves me 80 bucks how much am i
going to pay you
answer something less than 80 bucks
i'm gonna pay you 50 bucks
why because by paying you 50 bucks
and using up to 20 bucks of tools
equipment and raw materials
i will have 70 bucks of cost
for a 100 output the difference between
what i pay you and what i
sell the product for that's the surplus
you've produced it by your labor because
otherwise i couldn't produce it
i don't do anything you do the work i
sit there stare at you
you do the work you produce more
than you get for doing it
the difference between what i pay you
what marx calls
the value of your labor power and the
value that your labor
creates in that difference is the
surplus
and every worker in capitalism
knows it you know when you sit with the
employer
that the only way you would ever
be paid anything a million dollars an
hour
three dollars an hour the only way
you're going to get that money
is if hiring you brings him more
value than it costs him to hire you
because if it didn't he wouldn't hire
you
unless you were his son-in-law and maybe
not
even then okay great summation
and the existence of the surplus is what
equals exploitation
no exploitation means that there's a
surplus
appropriated by a person different from
the person who produced it
it's not exploitation okay okay cool
i've paid people i've paid people and
made
nothing the reason why i don't think
that this i have some issues the reason
why is because i don't think the surplus
or the labor theory of value takes into
account hope
or uncertainty but i'm sure it does like
i'm just a ruminantary
man okay i've paid people
and made nothing because i hoped that i
would make something from them
so who was being exploited there
it had nothing to do with hope you hoped
that you would make money
your employee hoped that you would make
money
because the employee has hope too hoping
not to lose the freaking job
hope that he didn't move his family from
timbuktu to wherever you are
and we'll have to move him again hope
that he doesn't have to yank his
teenager out of school
everybody's full of hope the difference
is
you make all the decisions and assume
the risk
he has risk i just went through the
risks your employee took
he took your job he could have taken
another job he moved to that town to get
the jar
he took all kinds of risks only he has
no control
over how the risk he took works out
you have all the control not only over
the risk
you took but the risk he took but worse
after you take the risk and let's hope
you're successful he still has the risk
that you'll fire him because you'll find
something else
that attracts your risk taking more i
mean
the degree of risk taking it the burden
is on him
not you only capitalists would have
imagined
the lopsided notion that because they
take a risk
and they don't want to understand what a
worker does when he or she takes a job
that they're the only risk taker
wouldn't it be more accurate to say both
people take risks
yeah both people take risks only one of
them
is rewarded for it only one of them is
stably rewarded for them the employee
he's not stable if you don't get the
satisfaction from the risk you've taken
if for whatever reason you don't like
this job
you think you can make more money
somewhere else he's taking the writ
you'll fire him
he can't even be sure that if he does
his job and you make money
you'll keep him on the job you may fire
him for someone else
all the risks is overwhelmingly on his
side i know let me let me push
please and correct me because okay i
have a contract with him and he's like
three months so you're secure in your
three-month pay
you get to work 40 hours a week at this
at 20
an hour for three months but i am
assuming the risk because i don't know
yeah if you're gonna that's wrong too
and i'll explain to you but then i have
to cut off because i have somewhere i've
got to be at 11. yeah
okay here it is um less than seven
percent of american workers today are
in the private sector are governed by a
trade union
that protects them with a legal contract
so in fact
you can fire a person no matter how many
months
you have worked out with him at no legal
risk
the person who works in the private
sector in the united states today
assumes all the freaking risk
you could be told to work in a different
way you can be told to work in a
different space
you can be told to suffer this kind of
quality air that kind of quality water
and you can be fired at any moment all
the risk is in the part of the employee
but he has no power you assume a risk
and you have power to determine how how
to pursue
this risk how to react to changing
circumstances
in this risk and how to utilize the
rewards
if your risk taking paid off i
understand
you take some risk but the notion that
you're the only you the capitalist or
the only one
is a kind of solipsistic conceit
that really blows my mind but look i do
have to go
i appreciate this send me a link if you
want to do it again
get in touch thank you so much sir all
right
all right take care man it was a
pleasure
pleasure pleasure man pleasure